scratch a tech entrepreneur and you find
hope that his product will change the
world for the better I've always felt an
inchoate suspicion when I hear Silicon
Valley talk about social change I've
never been able to put words to it
kentaro toyama has in his book geek
heresy rescuing social change from the
cult of Technology thank you for coming
in in your book you talk about these
experiments from the early 2000s the
computer in the wall in bangalore
nicholas negroponte a's one laptop per
child i was a tech journalist at the
time i wrote about these as if they were
amazing i was wrong we were all wrong
what was wrong with the idea that
technology could improve lives well
ultimately I always say that technology
amplifies underlying human forces and so
what that means is ironically exactly in
those places where we want technology to
have the most impact usually the human
forces are not aligned in a way to take
advantage of the technology so for
example with these laptops you know
exactly in the places where the
educational system is broken or
dysfunctional the technology doesn't
have a good capacity to Apple you went
to India for Microsoft as a hopeful
young man that you could actually change
the world you discover that you were not
completely right about that what does
Silicon Valley not understand about the
rest of the world I think the biggest
thing is they're living in their own
bubble where everybody you know believes
that the impact that the internet and
other technologies have on their own
lives necessarily transfer to other
people who don't have as much education
or political power well explain how this
works because you went out and did field
experiments that worked and you thought
this is great we can provide these
laptops these computers to other
students and then you didn't get the
results why that's right so in
experiments they worked and that was
because in the experiments we conducted
we worked in environments where we had
set up the conditions to be perfect you
know we had good teachers we had good
administrators go to Headmaster's and
then we ourselves kind of made sure the
technology worked those conditions don't
hold in exactly the schools where you
would want the technology to have
positive impact an economist would say
institutions matter you have to pay
attention to the context of where an
experiment is taking place that's true
in the US as well absolutely and that's
exactly what i found that institutions
matter you know i was amazed that when i
came back to the United States everybody
was so excited about more technology in
the classroom but really that only helps
in cases where the schools are already
doing well
schools that are struggling actually
struggle also to incorporate technology
what about m-pesa in Kenya that allows
people to transfer money over very
simple cell phones is that a
counterexample well that's a good
example of the technology amplifying
things in a positive direction so in
Kenya there was already an established
custom of urban migrants sending money
back home to rural areas and so this
system allowed them to do it cheaply and
more frequently you work for Bill Gates
when you were doing this he funds a lot
of these projects around the world does
he and do other people who fund these
technology projects get it are they
beginning to understand that you need a
foundation before you just throw
technology in there yeah I think so bill
gates is obviously you know incredibly
smart guy who is really interested in
changing the face of global poverty um
you know I think initially he had biases
that were kind of technological in the
same way that I did but over time he's
come to see that you know for example to
eradicate polio you need very strong
health institutions in place before you
can actually reach the people who need
vaccines you went to India you you you
you understood things better you came
home what is now the answer for people
who would choose who would want to use
technology to change the world so first
of all I don't think there's anything
wrong with using technology if you're
already doing something well and doing
it something good yeah you can of course
use technology to amplify your own
impact but the big error comes in
thinking that therefore the technology
is doing the magic it's really a
combination of the right person with the
technology and so spreading the
technology everywhere doesn't always
have the impact that everybody thinks it
will and I was really struck by you know
what you wrote about how this really is
true in America as well we have this
focus from the Department of Education
right now I'm getting you know iPads
into the hands of kids and you know what
you're showing in the book is that when
kids get iPads they play games exactly
and you know I mean everybody has seen
this you know if you see look over the
shoulder of a kid with a smartphone
they're playing angry birds they're not
playing educational apps so yeah what we
are solutions is more focused on
teachers on the people who actually
motivate the students to want to learn
rather than letting technology
absolutely i mean you know there's just
no way around good adult guidance for
for learning I mean I was in an
environment where i went to the same
high school bill gates went to and you
know this is a rich rich high school
with all the technology could possibly
want but what the what the parents want
for their kids when they need extra
boost for their child is more adult
guidance they were paying for me to be a
tutor and of course this is about money
technology can't be a substitute for
money in education is that well that's
exactly right well you spend money on
technology though it's the proper use of
the money the team to find the way to
actually make the impression on the
student right and I think you know one
of the things that we mistake is that we
think of education as being the content
and the technology often delivers that
content but really education is about
generating the right motivation in the
student and that requires good adult
guidance cantar toriyama I have to admit
I'm just a sucker for your book I'm in
the tank for it because he said exactly
what it is that I've been waiting for
somebody to say he says it well
definitely worth the read